are you still a virgin I am oh my God I
love this this is the most original
guest we've ever had on and you what are
you 39 I am oh my God that damn is going
to break one day baby and the thing
right now I like people were like oh you
know I I was like pray for him whoever
he is a lot of pet up energy up in here
but oh my God and you're going to hit
your sexual peak when you start having
sex so yeah you're going to need a coup
a men probably you all went from being a
Virg to
poy okay I wanted to point out a couple
things from this clip one how old
will always try to drag the more pure
women into promiscuity they will always
do this misery loves company when
someone is miserable they will try to
drag you into it